[Music]
Capitol Hill a busy place the subject of
funding Ukraine Israel the Border
Republican demands for changes in the
president's policy when it comes to the
Border all making for some tense final
days before Congress takes its holiday
break joining us to break it all down is
the new house Speaker Mike Johnson Mr
Speaker thanks for being here Brett
great to be with you first let me get
you to react to uh president sininsky I
know you met with him behind closed
doors and his concerned about funding
where does that stand and what what was
your reaction to what he said well I
didn't hear all of the interview but I
did spend some time with him today and I
told president zalinski uh a very clear
message it's the same thing I've been
telling to the white house uh since I
the day I got the Gabel and that is that
we stand with the Ukrainian people the
baguer people of Ukraine and against
Vladimir Putin's brutal uh attack his
invasion of their country but um we have
to get our own house in order first and
what I've told the White House and I
reiterated president zilinsky today is
that we have to have some clarity we've
been asking the White House for a clear
strategy that will allow Ukraine to
Prevail in this conflict and they've not
provided satisfactory answers we need
Clarity on the oversight over the
precious treasury the taxpayer dollars
of the UN American citizens and and we
need to know how that money is being
spent and and what the endgame is and
the White House has been completely
unclear about that is it possible that a
no Ukraine Aid could happen in the
Republican caucus well listen I I I
think that there is uh the majority of
the Republicans and the Democrats in the
house for uh by by way of example would
vote for Ukraine Aid if there is
sufficient Clarity on these questions
and also of course if we have U really
transformational change at the US border
well let's talk about that are there
significant steps that are happening
negotiations still going on uh with
secretary Mar orcus and others in the
administration about changes uh well I
hope so look I've been crystal clear
about this you know if we're going to
have a National Security package of
spending National Security begins at our
own border this is about our own
sovereignty um that these are policy
changes that could be easily made uh but
the White House has been very reluctant
uh they they really went silent on us uh
all of this time now I've been the
speaker for a little over six weeks
almost seven weeks and since the day I
was handed the gavl I've been saying
that this was the condition that we had
to do this first and and we passed hr2
the house passed our bill six months ago
it's been sitting on the desk of Chuck
Schumer ever since they've not taken us
seriously and here we are at the end of
the year and now they're saying we've
run out of time it's not the House's
fault yeah here is uh Senate minority
leader Mitch McConnell on the timing of
all this
ticklist they're leaving at the end of
the week so all I have said is
practically impossible even though we
reach an
agreement to craft it get it through the
Senate get it through the house before
Christmas that doesn't mean it's not
important
and even though we've been
emphasizing the Border I want to remind
everybody of the importance of you
Ukraine so just logistically is it would
you send the house home and then call
them back if there's a deal or you just
punt everything to January um look the
house will do its work if there was a
deal but it has not materialized and as
of tonight uh they have given us the
cold shoulders so they're ignoring this
what I believe is the top priority of
the people it doesn't matter where I've
been in the country over the last few
weeks Brett uh whether I'm in New York
or the southeast or out west they all
say the same thing they're deeply
concerned about what's happening we had
12,000 people come over that border one
day last week on Wednesday if you look
at the statistics from October November
and so far in December more people have
crossed that border illegally since any
entire year during the Obama
Administration it is not a sustainable
situation it is harming our country in
ways that are uh hard to describe and we
have to get on top so what's the red
line when it comes to border policy to
get the supplemental through listen the
The house's position is hr2 it has very
important Provisions like Asylum reform
parole reform the end of The Catch and
Release policies the if they don't go
all the way to hr2 could they get
someplace that's satisfactory it's it's
that's our position but they have yet to
come back and even volley anything over
the net so that's our position and we've
been very Resolute about that there are
a lot of other issues up on Capitol Hill
as I know you're figuring out as the new
house Speaker the hill writes this the
GOP Clash nixes Johnson plan for floor
Showdown on surveillance reforms
representative Dan Bishop uh Judiciary
member said he believes Johnson needs to
back one of the two proposals adding
that the queen of the Hill idea
epitomizes congress's stupidity Mike
Johnson is a great guy he's under all
the pressure that Washington brings to
bear and he'll figure out a path given
sufficient time this deals with Section
702 of the fisa ACT which lapses you
pulled two competing Bulls uh bills from
the
flooor where is this and do you think
it's been mishandled uh well it has been
mishandled it's a very complicated issue
section 702 of5 is what protects us from
attacks on the Homeland this is why we
haven't had another 9911 because of this
very important surveillance provision
and the law but it was also abused by
the FBI by our own uh government over
almost 300,000 times between 2020 and
2021 and so the civil liberties of
Americans have been jeopardized by that
it must be reformed we have two
Committees of jurisdiction working on it
simultaneously house Judiciary house
Intel they came up with two different
bills that have some pretty clear
distinctions between them and uh I
thought in the small D Democratic
fashion we should sort that out because
it's so important this is not any
regular area of policy this deals with
National Security and we got to get it
right so if it takes a little bit more
time to do that I think that's worth
that so that gets you to April and then
you got to get something ironed out yeah
well but I hope and and believe that we
can get it done in early January there
there is Con ensus on 38 of 45 reforms
that were composed by a large group that
worked on this and we've got to figure
out those final details and get it done
you know we talk a lot in the weeds here
on the show I think people know how
Washington works when they're watching
this you all did not do a single
spending bill after Thanksgiving um
there's really not Clarity what the top
line is so how do you avoid a government
shutdown when it comes to January
considering where you are right now yes
look we we did the continued resolution
into January and February and what was
really important about that this
Innovation is it broke the Christmas
Omnibus fever every year as long as I've
been in Congress and many years before
that the Senate would jam the house
right before the Christmas holiday with
a massive thousands of Page Long bill
that no one had read or amended or
debated and it would spend you know last
year 1.7 trillion um that's not the way
to run a railroad and so we broke that
fever we got it into January February so
now there's sufficient time to do the
negotiations we do need to agree upon
the final Top Line so that our
appropriators can get in the room and
hash it out uh but this isn't another
situation where we're waiting on the
Senate to act we sent our proposal which
is the statutory F uh number and um
they're they're just not responding and
so we're waiting on them to volley back
what's the top priority you're heading
into an election year you've got a very
slim majority and it's actually getting
narrower as you lose a couple of members
like George Santos and and others um
what's the top priority uh well the top
priority is to keep and grow our
majority why so we can save the country
country from the policies that are
destroying it uh the Biden
Administration in our view has been an
abject failure for the people the
Democrat uh majority in the Senate has
been accomplices in that and we've got
to turn this thing around I'm very
bullish on the future Brett I think
we're going to have a great election
cycle for conservatives and Republicans
because we're offering an alternative to
all this we have answers to all these
great challenges and our candidates and
our incumbents are excited to get out
there on the on the campaign Trail and
and talk about that because I think it
resonates with the people there's some
concern in the car us um that the push
for impeachment is losing some steam uh
do you see that uh and where do you see
impeachment of President Biden the
inquiry that opens up the the
investigation yes look you know my
background is constitutional law we
follow the Constitution I've said over
and over we're the rule of law team so
tomorrow we'll be voting on the inquiry
why are we doing that because it's the
next necessary Step the White House has
stonewalled this investigation it's gone
methodically carefully as the
Constitution requires of us it's a very
serious matter but right now they're not
turning over documents they're not
turning over key Witnesses and we'll
have to uh defend our subpoenas in court
so to do that you need an impeachment
inquiry vote from the full house we'll
have that tomorrow I believe it'll pass
and we'll be in the best position to
continue to do our constitutional
responsibility exactly four years ago uh
this is representative Mike
Johnson the founders of this country
warned against a single party
impeachment for good reason they feared
that it would bitterly and perhaps
irreparably divide our nation as the
next election in 2020 is drawing so
close now and their candidates for
president are so terribly weak they
obviously met somewhere at liberal High
command about 75 days ago and convinced
Nancy Pelosi they had to pull the
trigger I hope and pray that future
congresses can and will exercise greater
restraint so the moderates in your
caucus would say why not exercise
greater restraint now well we've shown
great restraint I mean there are a lot
of people who are frustrated that this
hasn't moved faster but there a big
distinction I stand by every word I said
in that video there's a big distinction
between what's happening now and what
the Democrats do th those were those are
rushed sham impeachments they did it
quickly they did not follow any of the
procedures that I just described uh we
have three committees investigating this
and following the truth where they lead
and they have no uh no no option in
doing anything else it's Ways and Means
Judiciary and oversight and they've
uncovered some alarming facts about the
Biden family and their dealings I
mentioned the house balance of power as
you look at it it's actually with the
vacancy Santos is one vacancy uh but
it's very very tight and you have a
number of GOP held districts where Joe
Biden won in 2020 17 without uh Santos
as you look ahead are you concerned
about this majority no I think we're
going to grow the majority I really do
and and I'm basing that on my experience
out in the field I've traveled to many
of these districts over the last few
weeks uh doing uh events in our
incumbent uh areas and even in the deep
blue States Brett we're we're running
very well Republican candidates are
running well and the reason is uh people
there are frustrated they have Democrat
leftist Progressive Governors and Mayors
who are destroying their economies and
crime is rising and all the other
problems and their Outlet then is to
vote for a republican for the house
because that really is the only option
they have to send a message that way and
so uh the polling is very good you know
fundraising is going well the Grassroots
is excited we have to deliver on that if
we can demonstrate that we can govern
well and I think we can I think we're
going to grow this majority I think
we're going to win the Senate and the
White House anti-semitism
uh seems to be going into politics here
people are really upset what they're
seeing in college campuses what they're
seeing in different parts of society
what's your take on that number one and
number two what possibly does the house
do about it well it's shocking to see
these college presidents as we all have
seen the video over one billion times
the video has been seen now of their
alarming answers that they could not say
unequivocally that the calling for the
genocide of the Jewish people violates
their values or or their codes of
conduct um it's outrageous uh one of
those presidents lost their position I
think the other two should as well uh
but but Congress is looking at a number
of measures one of them is oversight
over these institutions they receive a
lot of federal taxpayer dollars and we
want to know what they're doing with
that um I think there needs to be
accountability for this kind of thing
the the the rise in anti-Semitism uh is
just alarming and and Jewish uh students
at these institutions and people in
cities around the country are have great
apprehension a great fear about their
own safety right now it's just this is
not who we are as Americans we've got to
stand against it finally um working with
this Administration you know we have
this U we have this segment here on the
show Common Ground I I invite Democrats
and Republicans and a lot of your
colleagues have come up ranking members
and chairman to talk about what they're
doing as far as opposed to what they're
arguing about what do you think you can
get done with this Administration
considering your caucus considering the
narrow nature of how many votes you have
if the White House will be reasonable
for example On the Border Democrats
across the country are crying out for
relief from that open border it because
it affects every city from New York City
uh to places all around the country um
they're not being reasonable if they
will come to the table and work with us
we want to get important things done
there are a lot of challenges facing the
country uh I'm a goodfaith negotiator I
come uh in the spirit of wanting to work
together but they have not shown us any
indication that they're interested in
doing that and so the ball is quite
literally in their Court Brett and we're
ready to work to solve problems from the
American people but it takes both
parties to do that in in a in a place
where the margin is this small what
keeps you up at night um well the
concern about the debt which is our
greatest national security threat and uh
the the dangerous nature of the world
right now because we are projecting
weakness on the world stage and it's
inviting aggression these are very
serious times but again I'm very
optimistic about the future I think we
can get through this but we got a valley
to walk through here you did know you
were going to be in this spe this spot
is it everything you thought it was
going to be oh and so much less BR so
much less no look it's been a wild six
weeks but we're settling in and we've
got important work to do and we take the
responsibility seriously Mr Speaker we
appreciate your time thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else